jetzt scheint beim sex komplett
abzuheben und zwar im wahrsten sinne des
wortes das raumfahrtunternehmen ist der
lage mal eben so innerhalb von zwei
tagen zwei welten ein raketen zu starten
und alles läuft wie am schnürchen fast
damit gehört 26 fällen absolut führen
raumfahrtunternehmen oder besser ist das
absolut führende raumfahrtunternehmens
ein neues zeitalter des weltraum
verkehrt hat begonnen warum ist am
schluss immer dann doch noch knapp wurde
jetzt endlich zum science fiction
herzlich willkommen
zwei starb innerhalb von zwei tagen
dafür vielen anderen unternehmen und
nationen einfach die kapazitäten
zumindest scheint es momentan so in
maskat mit zwei staat innerhalb von zwei
tagen geschafft einen regelmäßigen
weltraum verkehr einzurichten den es
bisher so nicht gab und im juli würde es
wieder zwei starts geben und im august
in vier und so weiter und so fort
wandeln auf das recycling der ersten
stufe macht es möglich wobei das dieses
mal nicht klappt inzwischen klappt aber
wird es alles wirklich ziemlich perfekt
uns nicht nur die ersten wieder ein
drittel von raketenstufen haben
funktioniert sondern auch deren
wiederverwendung und auch das recycling
von dragon raumschiffen es ist wirklich
kapiert gestern setzte es bei 610 rund
600 kilo schwere iridium dafür bitten
für mobilfunk im all aus es war eine
absolute bilderbuch mission um 1 25 und
18 sekunden pacific daylight time rock
die folgen von pfannenberg stützung der
airforce in kalifornien ab zwei minuten
und 25 sekunden nach dem start wurde die
erste stufe abgeschaltet und durch für
mich vier sekunden später von der
zweiten stufe dann begann der rücksturz
zur erde drei minuten weg den sekunden
nach dem start wurde die hülle des
satelliten containers an der spitze der
völker lineup gesprengt um die
satelliten auszusetzen 9 sekunden später
klappen die steuer flächen aus titan an
der ersten stufe auf dem rückweg zur
erde aus füssen durch zünden immer
wieder die steuerdüsen um den kurs zu
korrigieren fünf minuten und 53 sekunden
später zünden die merlin man die
triebwerke um die erste stufe beim
wiedereintritt in die atmosphäre ab zu
bränden die triebwerke brennen wird
handel sekunden eine minute nach dem
zünden der merkt man die triebwerke
heiße sex on the beach iwf steht für
active vision of fitness das autonome
spaceport drohen chip auf deutsch
autonome weltraumbahnhof grund schiff
empfängt das signal von der ersten stufe
auf diese unbemannten schiff soll die
erste stufe gleich langen das schiff
heißt übrigens just read instructions
also lief einfach die
bedienungsanleitung dann sieben minuten
33 sekunden nach dem start sünden die
berliner die triebwerke zum zweiten mal
für die landung der ersten stufe und 15
sekunden später heißt es tat staunen die
erste stufe ist auf jobs
aktien gelandet neun minuten 14 sekunden
nach dem start werden die triebwerke der
zweiten stufe abgeschaltet 41 minuten
später werden wir noch mal für vier
sekunden gezündet dann ist die falcon 1
auf dem richtigen world orbit einer
niedrigen erdumlaufbahn 75 minuten und
22 sekunden nach dem start wird der
erste iridium dafür liebt ausgewählt es
ist nur wenig davon zu sehen eine stunde
zehn minuten und 40 sekunden nach dem
start wird dann satellit nummer 9
ausgesetzt und 100 sekunden später
nummer 10 eine absolut perfekte und
erfolgreiche mission
zwei tage vorher war nur etwas anders
aus die völker nein sollte den ersten
bulgarischen tage satelliten aussetzen
doch die lande bedingungen für die erste
stufe waren alles andere als optimal
schlechtes wetter über die pazifik auf
dem das autonome weltraumbahnhof
traumschiff of course the view auf
deutsch klar liebe ich dich noch
schwimmt aufgrund des eintritts winkels
werden die steuer flächen wir noch aus
aluminium sind zum glühen gebracht und
die landung ist so häufig dass alle
kameras während dessen ausfall die erste
stufe so dann auch noch die
landeplattform nicht zutreffen und
landet auch nicht wie am sonntag perfekt
mit ich sondern am rand es hätte nicht
viel gefehlt und sie wäre ins meer
gestürzt so aber ist dann doch noch
alles absolut nach plan gelaufen und
auch der satellit wurde auf den punkt
ausgesetzt und es kann weiter gehen und
es geht weiter
noch dieses jahr soll die erste falcon
heavy starten eine deutlich erweiterte
falke neuen herausforderung hier gilt es
drei elemente der ersten raketenstufe
wieder zur erde zurückzubringen
es bleibt also spannend bei spacex wenn
ihr kein video zu dem thema verpassen
wollt dann drücken wir hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergesst nicht dem auf die
glocke und hier geht es weiter mit einem
weiteren video über space 6000 raketen
zum mars einfach draufklicken wenn es
euch interessiert und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran